get more now on Greece's promise of
reform plans today we asked the
journalists at Philip pangalos who's in
Athens what kind of measures could be
introduced well we don't know the exact
details so far what we do know is that
the Greek government has formally
requested a third bailout loan from the
ESM that's the European Stability
Mechanism Europe's rescued fund so far
all they've said that that will include
reforms to do with taxation and reforms
relating to pension measures now the new
finance minister euclid chuckle or does
it was made a relatively positive
impression on his European counterparts
in comparison with his predecessor yen's
for a focus is due to put details of
their proposals probably by the able to
play today there was a deadline for a
Friday morning but I think he's going to
try and get them to Brussels I closed
the play on Thursday which would then
allow for a euro group to discuss them
that was due to be held on saturday but
i understand that could even be brought
forward to friday all we know so far is
that they're likely to ask for more than
50 billion euros and that is a third
bailout loan as we've said and they may
look for some short-term bridging
finance to tie them over but there will
be quite strong demands from the from
the creditors on the other side it's
going to be very difficult for Greece
because as we know they had this
referendum and a no vote and whatever is
going to be on the table is going to be
more demanding than what we had in the
past and it's gonna be a problem for
Prime Minister Alexis tsipras gotta
convince his hardline is within his
series I party to accept these it's
going to be difficult because it's going
to be more or circle starrett e it's
going to deepen the recession so one of
the things that they'll be looking for
is some measures for growth new jobs as
well as looking at the issue of debt
sustainability and this comes after US
President Barack Obama weighed in again
putting pressure on both German
Chancellor Angela Merkel and the Greeks
to do a deal jack blue the US Treasury
sector secretary has also said that it's
very important that all sides don't
under
estimate the possible implications of
Greece being forced out of the eurozone
and it's not just the financial
implications and certainly there would
be catastrophic for Greece but he's
worried about what it could mean for
Europe and also the global economy is
not just the economics it's also the
geopolitical position that Greece has
and I think the Americans are very
worried that an unstable Greece is bad
for Europe and bad for the global
economy